who do you speaking of which is the
greatest poker of uh player of all time
and why is it Phil Hellmuth
exactly you know mute probably knew this
question was coming uh yeah here's what
I'll say I think helmuth is the antidote
to computers more than any other player
playing today
and when you see him
in a heads up situation so I think like
he's played nine or ten heads up
tournaments in a row
and he's played like basically call it
10 of the top 20 people so far and he's
beaten all but one of them
when you're playing heads up you know
1v1
that is the most
um
GTO
understandable spot meaning Game Theory
optimal position that's where computers
can give you an enormous Edge the minute
you add even a third player the value of
computers and the value of their
recommendations
basically falls off a cliff okay so one
way to think about it is Helm youth is
forced to play against people that are
essentially trained like AIS
and so to be able to beat you know eight
out of nine of them means that you are
playing so orthogonally to what is
considered Game Theory optimal and
you're overlaying human reasoning
the judgment to say well in this spot I
should do X but I'm going to do y it's
not dissimilar in chess like what makes
you know Magnus Carlsen so good you know
sometimes he takes these weird lines
he'll sacrifice positions you know he'll
overplay certain positions or certain
you know Bishops versus Knights and all
these spots that are very confusing
and what it does is it throws people off
their game I think he just won a recent
online tournament and it's like by move
six
there is no GTO
move for his opponent to make because
it's like out of the rule book maybe he
read some game you know I read the quote
it was like he probably read some game
in some bar in Russia in 1954 memorized
it and all of a sudden by six moves in
the computer AI is worthless so that's
what makes helmuth great
the
there is one person that I think is
superior
um and I think it's what Daniel also
said and I would Echo that because I
played Phil as well but Phil Ivey is
um the most well-rounded
cold-blooded
bloodthirsty animal
and he
he's your soul Lex in a way where you're
just like oh my God stop looking at me
have you ever played him yeah yeah we
played we've played and you know he
crushes the games crushes the games